This even though I've never done it before.
So this is either gonna go really, really
well or extremely poorly.
I was checking out the community
forums where we get a lot of really
interesting and awesome questions.
And I came across
this one
that was asked yesterday.
What this user wants to do is to
be able to pull in some data from
a SQLite database
so that when they're querying their time series
data from InfluxDB,
they can actually
either map some
identifiers or and the time series data to
more descriptive values or maybe stored in a
relational store like SQL deep like SQLite. Sorry.
So it's quite a new use case that
is powered or enabled by the flux language
that our company and our flux team have
been working on now for a couple of
years
so that you don't need to store your
time series data
with too many indexed fields.
You know, some data as naturally relational
and being able to look that up and
augment it or, you know, join it or
correlate it to time series data, opens up
a lot of flexibility and power with your
queries and dashboarding.
So what I thought I would do
is
just
try and put something together that uses us
as an example.
Add that to my influx DB examples repository
so that a user can, you know, go
check it out, see how it works, and
use it for themselves.
But of course, step one is for me
to actually work out how to do this
and get it working.
So what I'll try and do is
get m flux d b two set up
and running.
We'll pull in some data using telegraph.
Then when I'm able to query that data
in the UI, we'll try and identify something
that could be
swapped out for data from a SQL store
even if we have to make that rather
contrived.
Then we'll do that.
So let's go to step one. Let's just
get our basic stack up and running.
So for that, I'm just gonna use Docker
Compose because I've done this a million times.
We'll have our InfluxDB
service,
and we're gonna use the Query.io
InfluxDB,
and we have a 2.2
beta image available.
Now I wanna be able to browse this
on my local machine,
so I'm just gonna do some port mapping.
And I said I wanted Telegraph.
So for this, we'll just use the official
Docker images,
And I wanna pass in a config.
So
telegraph.conf.
And that
will get me halfway there.
So now we need a telegraph.conf.
So I'm gonna wanna see data pretty quickly,
so let's go with a two second interval
and a flush.
Can't type. That's because I'm streaming.
We will enable our outputs
for influx d b b two,
not v three. That's a bit ambitious.
And what do we need here? We need
a URL.
This This is going to be our service
name on port nine nine nine nine. We
need an organization,
and we need a token, and we need
a bucket.
Okay. So what are these values?
Well,
we need to set up InfluxDB when we
spin it up. So what we're gonna do
here is just have a target and a
makefile,
where we'll run Docker Compose,
execute
in our influx DB container,
and we're gonna execute setup command.
I can be the user.
Super secure password.
Our organization name will just be my name
again.
We need a bucket,
which we'll call default,
and we need a retention
period policy.
Just retention. There we go. And if we
set that to zero or less, it will
be infinite.
So we have user password.
Oh, we need a token.
And the token is just gonna be Rawkode
as well. So now we have a setup
target that should configure NfoxDB when I get
it running.
What we're also gonna do is just configure
these here with the same values that we
used in that target.
So if I have done this correctly, we
should be able to spin the stack up.
Maybe I should have pre pulled the images.
And I wonder if I can get Twitch
on my phone so I can see if
anyone is chatting to me or if I'm
just talking to myself.
Yeah. I'm not a great singer.
Alright. We'll leave that there just now while
it installs.
So if I do docker compose p s,
telegraphed at exit. Let's see why before we
continue.
URL.
Okay.
Let's go check out the docs. So
telegraph
outputs.
There we go.
Once a a URL of influx d b's.
Okay.
URLs.
And let's try to spinning that back up.
Yep. We have Twitch installed.
Maybe a pain in the ass to log
in because of the two factor.
Twitch.
Take my picture. There we go.
Yep.
Get code.
I feel like I'm just mumbling to myself
now.
And submit.
Alright. Let's do a DS.
Guess they don't really need my headphones there.
Hi.
Alright. I think I'm talking to myself. That's
all good.
Okay. Let's check out the logs. What have
we got this time?
Org is not defined.
Organization.
Token and bucket.
So I get for using the short version.
Org organization.
And spin that up one more time.
Oh, you're joking.
No inputs found. Alright. Perfect.
So let's just enable internal,
which just gives us some stats about telegraph
itself.
Awesome.
So
we should
oh, we didn't run our setup command. Let's
do that. Make
setup.
And I got user wrong.
Oh, names.
That's a dreadful name for that argument.
Please type oh, no. Wait. Username. Hold
on a minute. So
config
name. That's a new feature, actually.
I don't think that had made any of
the releases yet, but you can actually have
multiple configs like a kubectl config.
Pretty cool, but we don't need that for
just now.
Okay. So let's go back here. This should
tell us it's already been set up. Perfect.
Let's go and log in.
Rawkode one two three.
And
if we're lucky,
which we're not,
we should see Telegraph writing some data here
pretty quickly.
So when was that? 11:33.
InfluxDB,
host not found.
That's annoying.
InfluxDB.
Okay.
What have I messed up?
Nothing.
So it does resolve it.
Okay. Let's jump inside of telegraph.
Oh, yeah. You don't need to interact flags.
Let's install
curl.
Oh, there we go.
And it's like DB9999.
Health.
Interesting.
Even though I can browse to it.
This is not where I expected to get
stuck.
So
maybe this is a new change
where nFlux d only lessens on localhost.
So let's try
this.
Although it says the default is
any and all.
Why is that not working?
Think, David.
Alright. Even though that says
it's the default,
I'm gonna check.
So that parameter was
h to b paint address
equals
zero dot zero dot zero dot zero,
and
we'll
just stop
everything.
Let's bring that back up.
Okay.
And let's go back
to telegraph.
Still not working.
Oh, trying.
Oh,
we have an error.
So the bank address needs a port too.
So let's bring that up.
We'll view the influx DB logs, Make sure
it actually gets into happy, healthy state.
Oh, hello.
Oh, you're clean.
Don't know if I'm saying that right. I
can barely read the tiny text on my
my phone.
Okay. So that seems okay now.
Come on.
Okay. Let's take a look at one I've
done before.
It's all InfluxDB one.
Some of these are InfluxDB two. This one
definitely is.
So
that's pretty simple.
Oh,
don't break it.
You know what? I know what it is.
No. I don't.
Maybe it's the order of the containers.
So let's try depends on
influx
DB
condition
service
started.
Destroy the world.
Oh,
what should be an array?
It
should be a string.
Okay. Go away.
Come back.
Let's check out our logs on Telegraph.
Okay.
Does it hit me?
Oh.
Okay.
Let's start poking around.
Let's try curl 1722003999.
That's probably localhost, isn't it?
Well, it does resolve.
17220029999.
I must have done something really daft.
Definitely running on that port.
Can I do it from local host?
Yeah. Because I got the browser at it.
So just
because I'm
so confused,
I'm gonna remove
this port mapping
and try again.
Okay. So there,
both healthy,
Curl.
Let's start again.
Maybe someone's helping me.
Yeah. Some confusion there too.
So remember when I was so confident at
the start, I said I've done this a
thousand times.
I mean, I have.
Alright. Let's send all
of my examples.
Let me use
Koli. So let's go with
that
runs that one.
Kubernetes.
No. That's just the image on that manifest.
Let's not do that.
Let's just copy this one then.
Or the comparison one. Let's see what's in
there.
Copy.
Paste.
Oh,
the version. I wonder what changed between two
and two point four.
Just for giggles.
Let's spin this back up with that.
I can't believe I'm stuck on this.
And plus d v two
and SQLite.
Yep.
We have
things looking normal.
And telegraph
still has this no route to hosting.
Alright. Let's just put this in. Delete chronograph.
We don't need
we don't need influx DB one. Maybe I'm
getting dishware enough to switch to that.
I'll try the alpha next.
We still wanna use telegraph one thirteen on
the m only mounting in the config.
We got rid of Prometheus.
We'll call this influx b b.
And I'm pretty sure that's the exact same
as what I had a second ago anyway.
But I'm desperate.
Check your networks with DC config.
Okay. We can do that in a second.
Alright. So we're still getting Norita host.
So
let's jump to the alpha,
and that well needs to download, so we'll
give that a minute.
Hold on.
Definitely
Docker Compose and not Podman Compose.
Okay. Start pulling that image.
Simplest compose fail ever.
Let's try
And let's just call it something different.
Still run the same image and put giggles.
Let's just get Elasticsearch
running too.
That might work.
It did work. Cool.
And let's get another tab,
and let's go inside.
Use the long version.
Seven
d.
Nope. Let's go and telegraph. 38
dash.
So we should have
available on 9999.
We
should have available there.
Bailed.
We should have elastic search available on 5
no. That's the wrong port. 920.
Right.
This is all of my containers.
I suspect
something is
well and truly fucked.
So let's spin up an example I've used
before.
There's no docker compose there. Let's go to
my demo from influx days,
which is under telegraph influx days
d c apt dash d.
Restart docker.
Good call.
System control.
Restart docker.
So
let's go back here. As that fixes it,
I'll be happy and mortifies it at the
same time.
TCPF.
DC logs telegraph.
Yeah. That's not fixed in it. Docker network.
Man, I'll explain.
Alright. Let's just forget Docker Compose.
Let's just do this also to make targets.
Let's not I'm not gonna waste time on
this.
Any more time on this. So let's run.
In fact, DB container
run.
Just kill it.
And we're gonna have to give this a
name because we're not using the network.
Publish the port
and the image name.
Telegraph, we'll do the same.
Doesn't need a name. It needs volume.
It needs a link and flux DB
an image.
And my setup command,
container,
exe c, we'll need IT,
and flex DB,
blah blah blah blah blah. Okay.
If this doesn't work,
I'm in trouble.
So influxDB.
I didn't attach them, did I?
Okay. ALS
running.
Make telegraph.
Okay.
What did I get wrong here?
Alright. Let's have it echo out of this
command so I can actually see.
Oh,
wait. This is make. There
we go.
Perfect.
So
let's get set up.
Docker container
logs.
We want.
Oh, motherfucker.
Let's not use containers.
So we'll install Telegraph. I do have nflux
d v two available already.
I wonder if there's a Telegraph bin package.
Yes. There we go. That should be fast.
Yeah. I mean, I definitely could use host
networking.
Let's just go
with the binaries.
There's clearly something broken with my Docker setup
on this machine.
So I'll probably just uninstall Docker after this
stream.
Never seen that before.
Very weird.
Okay. So we
do have
here.
So I should be able to just run
that. Oh, maybe let's just
run that here.
I'll wait for that to be healthy.
Bain address in use.
My containers will still be running one there.
Nine f and five b.
Okay.
Now we have influx.
Scan my finger, install Telegraph. Now we have
Telegraph.
So we don't need any of that crap.
We just need to point this to local
host.
We're still gonna set this up the same,
only we don't need
any container stuff.
Let's do make setup.
Perfect.
And
dash dash config.
Come on.
Give me some data.
Flash interval two seconds, which means that should
be working.
Rawkode.
One, three.
We have data.
Fucking hell. That was tough.
Alright. Okay. So let's just look at the
last five minutes. Refresh every five seconds. We
have data going up on a nice nice
linear progression there. So let's go back to
what we actually wanted to accomplish.
We have this post on the influx to
be community site.
The person is asking how they can, using
the flux query language, pull in some values
from SQLite to
augment that augment our time series data with
it.
So
first, I guess, now that we have influx
running telegraph,
we have some data.
We can take a look at that in
raw fashion.
And let's assume what we wanna do is
update the name of the host.
So we have Arch right now.
Maybe we actually wanna give that a nicer
name, and we wanna fetch that from a
relational database of some sort. And we're gonna
use SQLite.
So what do I need to do?
First, I'm gonna need some SQLite
data.
So let's go back to this directory.
SQLite
browser.
Yep.
Get that installed.
Create a database.
Code source.
GitLab.
I should've used something in the top there,
or should've.
We're learning lots today. That's good. Alright. Main
SQLite
three.
I think that's extension.
We'll call this host.
We'll give it a ID,
which we're gonna make it string,
non null primary key,
all the happy stuff.
We'll give this a nice name
text
also can't be null
and that's hopefully enough to get started.
How do I add data?
Oh, there we go.
So we wanna enter arch as the ID
and
we're gonna give this a nice name of
awesome
arch machine.
Right.
Cool.
I guess that's it.
Wonder what SQLite fail looks like.
Is that it?
When do they get that syntax in it?
No. Okay.
Alright. Regardless.
So we wanna start using this inside
of our data explorer.
So what I'm gonna do
is jump over to the script editor.
We can keep running that query, get a
graph.
I know. Let's just comment that out.
Jump back to this post
and just start by copying what they have.
So import
from SQL.
My file is called main dot SQLite three,
and I called that.
Hosts.
I'm seeing the raw data.
Go.
Alright. Now that's the same error.
I'm sure.
Yeah. That they got.
So I mean the main thing I'm thinking
right now is just that this path is
not a path. It's just a filename.
I can't even remember if it's the same
directory I run influx d from.
So, actually, I'm now really gonna regret this
path, but let's grab this.
Try main SQL eight three.
Still broken.
Right. Let's simplify that path then.
In fact, we'll copy it to temp
main.db
just because that's what they called theirs.
Main.db.
Let's try that.
TMP main
d p.
Still broken. No. Failed pass. When you use
this format,
sometimes one, sometimes two, sometimes three. Let's try
them all.
No. Definitely broken.
Okay.
So this
uses the go
SQL library,
I believe.
Let's see if we can find an example
from that.
Let me just check the cool mod fail
that sucks
Flux.
Oh, that is a good point.
Is this only available in Flux Rapple, or
will it be available
in in FluxDB?
Alright. It looks like it may work. Okay.
Go mod. Go mod.
SQL.
Here we go.
Go SQL nine three.
Hey, Kieran.
Alright. How does this fucking work?
So
what is that?
It?
I'm getting really fed up with seeing that
example.
It doesn't
mean anything.
Alright.
Let's search for a fail.
Seems to be the keyword here.
I
mean, that was
thoroughly useless.
Let's try
let's just search this whole repo.
Let's
try
and force a cool on.
Oh, thanks, github. It was useless.
So what does that mean?
Could it be
I mean, do we need
that? No. Maybe.
Let's check out the docs.
Fucking example.
Alright. So
should we
try
pull scripts first?
Let's try some
let's see if we get any logs. Where
is
and blocks.
Nothing
whatsoever.
Okay.
That's
not very useful.
How about
let's go to
right now, I'm thinking this is potentially an
issue with the influx
DB build.
Maybe the flux library being a bit older.
So let's try and get it working with
just straight up flux first.
So I need to compile this.
Go modules
on
go build
c m d
flux.
Hopefully,
it won't take too long.
We'll copy that flux script,
and I will make it my mission
to get rid of every
example
that has
that.
That's my my my new life's purpose.
Let's take a read of that example everywhere.
Oh,
come on flux, compile.
So the really cool thing about running or
at least running flux as a standalone binary
if there's a ripple,
I'm hoping we're gonna get slightly better
error logs on what is actually going wrong.
Although that's the
best guess right now.
Well, I've been streaming forty minutes, and I've
gotten nowhere.
So what can I do just now? Alright.
So we have no logging here.
I mean, is there any other file
formatting path that I'm missing?
Where did I okay. Let's try where did
I run influx d from?
What directory? Is that just my home?
I mean, I can kill it. Yeah. Okay.
So let's copy the file there too.
All that finished, which is good, so we'll
come back to that.
Don't care about telegraph at this moment in
time, so let's copy our main
to home main.db.
And,
I mean, I'm the same user. It it
just shouldn't matter.
And let's try opening it now.
No.
And because
I'm just
very curious.
Main DB.
Maybe it just doesn't work.
Maybe that's what we're getting to here.
Alright. Let's run.
Oh, I just changed them to the right
here instead of running it. There we go.
Flux. Good.
Ruffle.
And your own time.
There we go. So let's import
SQL.
And I'm about to
let's just copy this.
Interesting.
That is interesting.
Let's try and get this on one line.
So it said no
table,
which is, I think, progress. Unless InfluxDB is
just swallowing that, and that's the same error
we've had the entire time.
Now let's try
doing the temp one.
And then let's try incorrect
path and see if it's at the same.
That's annoying.
No such table
hosts.
Let's try two slashes.
Oh,
that's definitely
different. Let's try three.
Alright. So two seems to be the magic
incantation here.
Oh, no. That failed to exist anyway.
Why does that give us an SQL logic
error?
It's
still called main dot DB, isn't it? Yeah.
Oh, wait. Temp. Temp.
Yep.
SQL logic error.
No.
We do have a table called hosts.
Open database.
TMP
main
DB.
Tables,
hosts.
Select
star from hosts.
Yep.
So maybe this has just never been tested.
So there's a good idea.
Let's look at the test suite.
So
where would this be? Standard loop
SQL.
Yep.
SQLite test.
We're gonna get there.
Alright. Let's see. So write values to the
DB.
So I wonder if we could try that.
Maybe we could try, like, a create tables
command
rather than pulling anything
out.
Curious.
Let's see if we can find fail colon.
No.
Oh, wait. That's just a I'm just using
the memory one, aren't they?
Dot open. Memory. Memory. Memory.
Memory.
It looks to me like we need a
test that actually opens a fail
I wonder why the two slashes gives me
that logic thing.
Oh, wait. Hold on a minute.
Mode equals memory.
What does that do?
Try slash.
Quite happy with that.
Okay.
There's mode memory. I noticed that in
the test,
which stops it opening the file. So let's
jump back here,
and we're just gonna go back to main
DB
cache shared.
Take that off.
Oh, come on. Okay. Let's try it from
flux.
Oh, wait. We did. Okay. It worked.
Fail,
colon,
main DB.
So it doesn't work in influx DB,
but it does work here on the command
line with the Flux repo.
And I
don't believe
there is
anything different in those queries.
Now the problem just could be that it's
not time series data,
so let's try saying
nice names equals,
and then let's bring back in this query
because the UI
can get a little bit funny.
I'm bringing a computer. So so now I
think this is working,
but the UI needs to see things in
a very particular format. So let's try
doing a map.
Pass in the row.
We wanna execute some code.
What we're gonna do here is return
r with,
and we're gonna add nice name.
And right now, let's just put my username
and check if the syntax works.
No. What have I got wrong?
Because I'm using multiline.
Uh-huh.
And that gives us a nice name of
Rawkode.
So let's now see if we can
pull something out of this nice names
variable. Now the
UI doesn't provide great debugging tools. Let me
turn off that refresh.
For our introspection, what this value even looks
like.
So for now,
let's pull in JSON and see if I
can get a JSON representation
of it.
Nice names.
Unknown type.
It's an array according to this.
Thank you, LSP.
I
should be able to
encode
an array, but it might just be
we expect a string there. Perfect.
So
So that's not executed
a query.
In fact, I'm just getting back
Data source name.
Yeah. It's not really what I want.
What I want is that.
How do I get that?
Do we have access to anything?
Result.
No.
So it comes back here. Yeah. Result. Result.
Result.
Nope.
What a brick. What a brick.
Okay. Let's try
temp.
Yeah. We're just gonna send back. And then
just because I wanna see if it actually
fail if it ever does.
No.
So there must I guess I mean, I'll
need to check with the flux team, what
I can kind of tell right now,
maybe there's a version mismatch.
Definitely working here.
I get back what I want. I get
my ID. I get the nice name.
I'm just not getting
anything here.
Select star from point. Yeah. I mean, it's
the same query I pasted in.
I
think I'm at a loose end,
but
we we fixed a few things.
We did get it opened. We did get
the results using flux,
which is good,
But we can't
bring that over to influx DB.
Alright.
I'm gonna finish up shortly. If anyone has
any questions on what you've seen or parts
seen or wanna see something else, I'll give
you a few minutes while I mumble to
myself about what else I could try.
And I think I'll shut this down, grab
some lunch, and then pick up another community
issue after lunch and see if I can
get a bit more success.
Do we have any examples?
I mean, I could always spin up a
Postgres, I guess.
But the question was about SQLite.
And this example is just wrong.
I think when fail is here, mode memory
needs to just disappear.
That's definitely what broke it from here.
Yeah.
Because it's it's saying it's not memory SQLite
store from what I can tell.
So that's good. We can update that. We
can fix that.
And it's a path which we can document.
That's creating
I mean, can I create?
Let's try that. So
I create
table
new table.
I mean, can I just do that?
I'm gonna show
my lack of knowledge here. SQLite
create.
Maybe create database is a bit easier. I
don't know if that is that is a
database.
Alright. Let's see.
Just
give me an example. Perfect.
You are the one.
Read only.
Okay.
How do we open?
Open.
Retry.
What's the magic incantation for that?
Mode equals
can I just do RW?
Nope.
That would have been too nice.
Maybe we should look at
the library we're actually using,
which was on one of these tabs.
Yep.
I always wish that Chrome had a command
palette like Versus Code where I could just,
like,
type in roughly what I want.
Okay. Alright.
Good. Mode.
RW.
Now I was sure
there was SQL two support. Yeah.
Which means I must be able to open
it.
I just read right.
There's a fucking memory again.
Sorry. My language is dreadful.
Okay.
So there's no mention of even
attempting to open this in readwrite mode.
So access mode of the database.
Okay. Let's take a look at SQLite open.
Yeah. We've already been on that page.
Mode equals
RO.
Read only.
Definitely
not having a lucky day.
Mode equals rewrite.
So maybe my cache
then
is disabling this.
So
can I just remove that?
I feel like I'm clutching it's dry, but
it's definitely not really gone, though.
Wait.
What could it be?
I ran the flux process as myself,
so it shouldn't be permissions.
Let's try the temp one.
Oh,
okay. It was permissions.
So let's try opening
that
and this.
We have our new table.
K. Let's try that from here, which was
our plan
to see if,
well, I can't remember.
Definitely had a plan, though.
I wanted to see if it was just
inversion mismatch.
So we're gonna try this.
Let's try t two.
Oh, we still need this to actually do
something so the UI doesn't give us an
error.
Two.
Oh, too much.
Yeah. That's fine. Whatever.
Did that create t two?
That is a question.
Temp.
No.
Alright.
Okay. So,
yeah, definitely
the SQL stuff
just doesn't
oh.
Let's take off this map just just in
case it's the error.
Let's see the query work.
Say what?
Let's try assigning this to nothing.
Okay.
Just double check how do I reload?
Can I
open it again?
Yeah. It doesn't
I mean, I'm just gonna have to be
super sure.
It doesn't seem like I can do much
from
MySQL,
the NTP
version. Yeah.
So we're not getting that table.
Interestingly enough,
it is trying to have some sort of
result
here
just because I hate things
being unanswered.
R
with
SQLite,
which is gonna be string
v JSON
encode
the
result.
What if I go wrong?
Map.
RMov.
I just got a wrong number. One, two,
three, four.
Oh, wait. I don't need to surround
that. Right? No.
And the string function is called string. Right?
Let's just use multilane.
Return.
Wrap that in object syntax.
Close JSON.
Close string. Close that.
Close this this.
Okay.
Yeah. We're not getting a result back. Keep
in mind,
I was complaining. I don't know. I think
I'll need to speak to some people on
the team about what's actually going on here.
So in response to this person's question,
I
have no idea.
I don't have enough history to go back.
I'll go back to it in a minute.
Okay. So we could get it working from
Flux CLI,
but we cannot get it working from InfluxDB.
I'll need to
get that docs fixed on,
speak to our Flux team,
and see if this is just that InfluxDB
hasn't got the latest and greatest version or
if there is something more sinister.
Maybe there's some security implications about
loading from the desk, maybe,
when fluxes
and the sandbox environment that influx DB provides.
I'm not sure.
Anyway, that's been an hour and five minutes.
I'm gonna grab some lunch, and I'll be
back in a bit. But if you persevered
with me, thank you for joining me. Let
me know what you thought on Twitter.
And anything you wanna see with influxDB,
flux, or any surrounding monitoring
or observability technology, just let me know.
Thanks for your time.